unser top thema heute atommeiler länger
am netz die kernkraftdebatte spaltet die
politik verabschieden sich die grünen
von ihrer partei dna das top thema jetzt
im zdf morgenmagazin
ja jede kilowattstunde zählt sagt der
grüne bundeswirtschaftsminister robert
habeck und nun in dieser situation haben
die grünen ein dilemma ja denn wenn das
so ist dann müsste man ja eigentlich die
atommeiler etwas länger laufen lassen
oder nicht fragen dazu gleich an die
stellvertretende ministerpräsidentin aus
nordrhein westfalen sie ist auch von den
grünen zuvor kerstin lienzer mit einem
überblick
es ist ein stresstest für die ampel
streck betrieb wiederaufnahme oder doch
der ausstieg eigentlich sollten
atomkraftwerke bis ende des jahres in
deutschland ausgedient haben doch dank
eu das sparziel und energiekrise ist die
neue alte debatte wieder aktuell
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
hält eine längere nutzung für
erforderlich es muss in jedem fall eine
stromlücke verhindert werden und
zugleich darf das nicht mehr für die
energieproduktion eingesetzt werden weil
das so knapp geworden ist es ist ja zu
erwarten dass in den nächsten monaten
und möglicherweise auch jahren verstärkt
mit strom auch geheizt wird auch
oppositionsführer friedrich merz spricht
sich für eine laufzeitverlängerung
deutscher atomkraftwerke aus wir müssen
einen weiterbetrieb solange ermöglichen
bis die gefahr eines engpasses beseitigt
ist die bundesregierung muss sich jetzt
um neue brennstäbe bemühen aktuell
laufen in deutschland noch drei
reaktoren isar 2 in bayern
neckarwestheim 2 in baden-württemberg
und emsland in niedersachsen
eigentlich sollten diese bis zum ende
dieses jahres abgestellt werden die
atomkraftwerke bruckdorf grunde und
gundremmingen c waren ende 2021 im zuge
des schrittweisen atomausstiegs vom netz
gegangen diese seien laut tüv verband
aber noch immer voll funktionsfähig
unseren prüfung im märz diesen jahres
haben ergeben dass die drei
abgeschalteten auch in einem solchen
zustand sind dass sie wieder anfahre
wären es gibt ein paar voraussetzungen
zu erfüllen zum beispiel
sicherheitsüberprüfungen die gemacht
werden müssten dass ein zeitraum in
anspruch da reden wir von monaten aber
auch keinen fall jahren die linkspartei
ist gegen eine längere so ein deutscher
akw s so auch die mehrheit der grünen
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck
schließt eine verlängerung aktuell nicht
mehr aus jedoch will er zuerst den
zweiten stresstest zur sicherheit der
stromversorgung abwarten
die nrw ministerin für wirtschaft und
energie ist mir jetzt zugeschaltet sie
ist auch die stellvertretende
ministerpräsidentin
aus nordrhein westfalen mona neubaur
schirm und morgen schön
robert habeck schließt ja den
weiterbetrieb von den drei noch
laufenden atommeiler unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen nicht mehr aus auch weil
der anteil des stroms der durch akw
produziert wird bei sechs bis sieben
prozent liegt sind sie auch für einen
sogenannten streck betrieb
ich würde die lage beschreiben als ernst
aber stabil wenn es um die
energieversorgungssicherheit geht und
was wir gerade erleben ist ja dass wir
fest steigen gerade atomkraft ist teil
des problems in der energieversorgung
auch in der stromversorgung wende nach
frankreich blicken also warum muss es
gehen ernsthaft zu überprüfen sicher
durch den winter zu kommen deswegen es
ist richtig dass jetzt ein weiterer
stresstest durchgeführt wird im auftrag
des bundeswirtschaftsministeriums und
entlang der dann vorliegenden fakten
entschieden werden kann der tüv hält ja
jetzt sogar die nutzung der ende 20 21
stillgelegten drei akw für machbar und
sicher und sagt zitat das sei keine
frage von jahren sondern eher so von
monaten oder wochen es scheint also nur
eine frage des politischen willens zu
sein also worauf warten sie konkret ich
finde sie sprechen mit dem politischen
willen ganz wichtigen punkt an es ist
doch interessant dass gerade die treiber
der diskussion um eine mögliche
verlängerung der atomkraft in der
bundesrepublik aus der csu kommen dem
bundesland das sich weigert ausreichend
dazu beizutragen dass die netze
entsprechend nach bayern gelegt werden
dass der ausbau der erneuerbaren
passiert ich würde mich freuen den anruf
von meinem kollegen aus bayern zu
erhalten und gemeinsam die initiative zu
starten windkraft und erneuern war in
einem nicht dagewesenem maße auszubauen
bei dass die strukturelle antwort auf
die herausforderungen der zukunft ist
unabhängigkeit von fossilen
energieträgern die an den börsen preise
produzieren die die wirtschaft belasten
die die verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
belasten also die strukturelle antwort
für die zukunft ist der massive ausbau
der erneuerbaren und das sehr kluge
einsätzen von energie also energie
einsparen und energieeffizienz frau
ministerin jetzt sagen sie ja selber die
zukunft die zukunft ist natürlich auch
morgen und übermorgen aber das was sie
sagen ist ja vor allem was langfristiges
wir müssen aber doch über jetzt über dem
herbst über den winter sprechen und da
sind doch die verlängerung der akw
möglich weise doch eben relativ sinnvoll
also dieser strecke betrieb auch dem
schließen sie aus
ich stelle fest dass die maßnahmen die
ergriffen wurden nämlich jetzt schon gas
einzusparen wirkung zeigen wir
verbrauchen knapp 15 prozent weniger gas
in den ersten monaten des jahres 22 als
im vorjahr das heißt es bringt was dass
sich industrie auf den weg macht dann
überlegt wo können wir einspannen alle
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher
wirklich die bitte rufen sie ihren
eigentümer ihrer mietwohnung an oder
wenn sie selber eine gas etagen heizung
haben kümmern sie sich darum dass diese
gewartet wird dass sie selber dazu
beitragen weniger gas einzusetzen darum
geht es doch jetzt wir müssen uns
vorbereiten auf den engpass in der
gasversorgung und alles tun jetzt so
viel gas wie möglich ein zu speichern
und noch mal entschieden wird die frage
von atomkraftwerken entlang der
ergebnisse des weiteren stresstest aber
sie sagen doch auch genauso wie robert
habeck jede kilowattstunde zählt also
das ist ja richtig müssten doch die
atommeiler länger am netz bleiben ich
habe ja gerade die zahlen schon gesagt
also der anteil des stroms der durch akw
produziert fertig bei sechs bis sieben
prozent das ist jede menge und der
anteil denen die atomkraftwerke und der
energie daraus in unsere besonderen lage
einer möglichen gasmenge lage leisten
kann liegt ungefähr zwischen 0,2 und 0,9
prozent also wer jetzt versucht
politisch zu sagen mit diesem einen mit
dieser einen maßnahme dann haben wir
alle probleme gelöst der spielt nicht
ehrlich der macht vielleicht polizei
partei strategisch in klugen muss für
seine eigenen interessen aber im
interesse der wirtschaft im interesse
der bürgerinnen und bürger ist es
richtig alles dafür zu tun an allen
ecken und enden jetzt energie gas
einzusparen sich vorzubereiten und alles
dafür tun dass wir so sicher wie möglich
durch den winter kommen und dann und ich
komme noch mal darauf zurück
selbstverständlich wird ernsthaft
überlegt und ernsthaft getestet in
diesem stresstest aber wir warten die
daten und die fakten ab und entscheiden
dann also fünf monate nach beginn des
krieges wollen sie dann also jetzt
diesem stresstest durchführen das hätte
man vielleicht sich auch schon etwas
eher überlegen können aber gut ist ihre
kraftwerke werden einer läuft schon
genau was wenn ja dann wahrscheinlich
noch weitere folgen möglicherweise
müssen jetzt kohlekraftwerke einfach
noch mehr leistung aber wir haben jetzt
viel über sparen auch gesprochen und sie
haben ja gerade bürger bürgerinnen die
zuschauerinnen auch dazu aufgerufen ab
dem ersten august sollen in deutschland
15 prozent gas gespart werden wenn wir
uns jetzt mal auf ihr land nordrhein
westfalen konzentrieren wo genau wollen
sie sparen und wie
wir haben hier in nordrhein westfalen
sehr engen austausch mit den
vertreterinnen und vertretern der
kleinen und mittelständischen
unternehmen der industrie mit natürlich
der verbraucherzentrale um alles zu
aktivieren was wir aktivieren können das
heißt wir überprüfen inwiefern zum
beispiel können wir als landesregierung
auch den notwendigen beitrag leisten
dadurch dass wir prüfen wie wir die
temperatur absenkung unserer
heizungsanlagen in den ministerien
gewährleisten könnten auch damit einen
kleinen beitrag dazu leisten weil wir
jetzt nur durch diesen winter kommen
werden wenn wir das solidarisch machen
wenn wir uns unterhaken das heißt
angebote zur förderung vom einbau von
effizienzmaßnahmen in der industrie das
zu unterstützen die genehmigung für den
fußweg so schnell wie möglich zu
erteilen das sind die aufgaben das sind
die hausaufgaben die jetzt in den landes
wirtschaftsministerien auch in nordrhein
westfalen auf dem schreibtisch liegen
wir arbeiten konzentriert wir arbeiten
für eine lösung die ehrlicherweise auch
die beispiellose europäische solidarität
die wir ja gerade erfahren dass alle mit
erz länder der europäischen union sagen
wir sparen ein unabhängig ob sie selber
von gas aus russland abhängig sind da
sind wir jetzt selber dran zu sagen wir
können wirksam werden wir können energie
sparen dafür arbeiten wir hier über die
ressorts hinweg für die menschen und für
die industrie in nordrhein westfalen
sagte nrw ministerin für wirtschaft und
energie monat neubauer vielen dank für
ihre zeit und für das gespräch sehr
gerne dann clean